imagine that you're a manufacturer and
one of the things that you're trying to
deal with is the potential cost for
outages in your production line the cost
that might occur if any of your
equipment goes down and stops the
production process or imagine that you
are an automobile industry manufacturer
and you're trying to enhance the
experiences in your car you're trying to
engage your clients your passengers your
drivers into a better driving experience
or to give them the ability to
understand the features of your car in
ways that the manual doesn't really
offer by itself all of these examples
lend themselves to being enhanced and
extended using analytics using AI to
infuse a better experience into the car
driving environment that analytic though
has the problem that it needs to run
locally it needs to occur with lower
latency it needs to be performed without
requiring a whole bunch of data to flow
back to the cloud or to your IT data
center we need to take advantage of the
compute capacity that exists in those
environments to be able to perform the
analytic that's there to enhance the
experience to be able to recognize the
potential of the machine to fail and be
able to respond to that in real time so
these capabilities are being offered by
IBM in a product that we call IBM edge
computing this has a couple variations
including support for edge servers as
well as edge devices both of which
enable us to deploy and manage workloads
into these devices into these servers at
massive scale with security and
integrity and be able to manage the
diversity and dynamism of those edge
computing environments in addition IBM
Global Services are creating solution
offerings that are tailored to specific
industries and particularly use cases
that not only deliver on that value but
accelerate your time to market so with
edge computing we can bring that
analytic and perform it right there on
the machine itself we can reduce the
latency we can decrease the amount of
bandwidth is required we can improve
of the security and the protection of
the data that's produced off of that
machine we can look for enhancements in
user experiences on the machine that
delivers the value of being able to
reduce that cost over time